So the answer is actually zero seconds that this will
take very little time. It won't be exactly no time
but very close to zero seconds. And the very reason
for this is because of both the way make_big_index works.
Which creates an index where the words start with four
A's, and we keep increasing the letters as we go.
So that means the index created by make_big_index passing in
any number. The first entry in that index will always
be aaaaaaaa, and so when we do the lookup, the way
lookup works, it goes through the entries in order, and it's
going to find the first entry right away. So the point
I want to make with this quiz is that the execution time
depends on both the size of the input, and sometimes it
depends on the actual input. So here the size of the
index is very big, because we looked up a word that's
at the very beginning of the index, the lookup is very fast.